Everybody loves Disney movies!
From kids to adults, pretty much everyone
seems love getting lost in the fun stories,
characters and songs from the world of Walt
Disney.
These movies are also famously stuffed with
hidden easter eggs, messages and references
and over the years they have led to some pretty
awesome and convincing theories.
We’ve gathered some of the best ones for
our list of 10 Disney Movie Theories That
Actually Make Sense.
Enjoy this video and be sure to click that
subscribe button for more awesome Screen Rant
content, every single day!
Snow White Dies
Snow White is the oldest feature length animated
Disney movie and it famously ends with a nice
happily ever after scenario, or so we thought.
It turns out that Snow White’s Prince Charming
may not be who we all assumed he was after
all.
One well respected theory suggests that instead
of the knight in shining armor everyone has
thought he was, that he’s actually the Grim
Reaper, who has arrived to escort Snow into
the after life.
This theory is pretty creepy and definitely
not great for kids, but when you consider
the dark origins of most fairy tales, it totally
makes sense.
Ariel's Mom
Disney is no stranger to Easter eggs and hidden
messages, but this one must have taken some
serious planning as the two movies came out
thirty years apart.
The mermaids in Peter Pan may have been forgettable,
but when you look closely you can see that
one of them has bright red hair and greatly
resembles Ariel.
We never get to meet Ariel's mother in The
Little Mermaid, we do get to learn that her
name is Athena, and the mermaid in Peter Pan
is never named, meaning her name could conceivably
be Athena.
It is also revealed that Athena was killed
by pirates, and the mermaid in Peter Pan would
have been around while Captain Hook was at
large, so it’s definitely possible that
he offed her.
Andy’s Mom in Toy Story
The action of the series mainly follows the
toys of Toy Story, but as it turns outs one
of the most interesting and convincing theories
from this franchise is all about the owner
of the toys.
In Toy Story 2, fans found out that Jessie
was originally owned by a girl named Emily,
before she was sadly given away.
But many fans have pointed out that the movie
seems to indicate that Emily is actually the
mother of Andy, who of course owns all the
main toys.
In the first story, Andy is playing with Woody
while wearing Jessie’s hat – the same
one Emily played with when she was younger.
Since 30 years have passed since Emily gave
Jessie away, the age makes sense.
This seems far too convenient to not be true
and we are happy that it gives Jessie a happy
ending to her story.
Elsa and Anna are Rapunzel's cousins.
This is one of the most famous theories on
the list and by this point it has pretty much
been accepted as the truth.
Rapunzel and Eugene are very clearly seen
arriving at Elsa's coronation, and considering
they don't live in Arendelle, they must be
very important guests.
Also, Both Rapunzel and Elsa are blonde, and
both have powers that look pretty but are
somewhat unorthodox.
This would also explain why the King was so
tough on Elsa about her powers as he would
have seen his niece imprisoned for having
powers and would want to protect her.
Future Aladdin
Aladdin is one of the most beloved Disney
movies of all time, but it turns out that
fans may be mistaken as to when the action
of the film takes place.
At the beginning of the film, the genie complains
that "10,000 years will give you such a crick
in the neck!"
He then spends the rest of the movie making
references to modern culture such as Jack
Nicholson and Arnold Schwarzenegger.
So unless the magic lamp has been sitting
in front of a TV in the Cave of Wonders, we
have to assume Aladdin takes place 10,000
years from now.
This theory also suggests that the action
takes place in a post-apocalyptic post war
middle east.
None of this really changes the plot of the
movie, but it’s definitely fun to think
about!
The Little Mermaid's Ariel and Hercules are
cousins
This theory is very easy to believe as long
as you have a basic understanding and appreciation
of Greek Mythology.
In The Little Mermaid, Ariel's father is King
Triton, who is famously the son of Poseidon,
the god of the sea.
This would make Poseidon Ariel's grandfather.
Greek mythology also says that Poseidon is
the brother of Zeus, who is, of course, the
father of Hercules both in the movie and in
the mythology.
This means that King Triton and Hercules are
first cousins, making Ariel and Hercules first
cousins once removed.
With all these crazy characters in the one
family, that’s definitely a reunion we want
to be invited to!
The Emperor's Dark Groove
Some Disney moves are intentionally dark but
it’s always been pretty well understood
that The Emperor's New Groove is just a fun
movie with a goofy llama and a ridiculous
villain, right?
Well, It turns out The Emperor's New Groove
has a really dark side, that has slipped past
viewers for years!
While Kuzco is walking through the jungle,
he sees a fly get eat…only that fly wasn't
just a fly; it was a human who had been turned
into a fly.
This is known because only animals who have
once been human are able to speak in the movie,
and Kuzco can clearly hear the fly scream.
Essentially, if all of this checks out, this
scene feature the brutal murder of a human
child.
Bing Bong lives!
Inside Out was a major hit in 2015 and it
was no surprise when it took home the Academy
Award for best-animated film.
While many of the main characters in the film
were literally emotions, the most emotional
character in the movie was Bing Bong.
His ultimate sacrifice and his death brought
a truly heart breaking moment, but don’t’
be too sad because it turns out that it may
have not actually happened at all.
Why?
Because a great fan theory suggests that Riley’s
imaginary friend Bing Bong is actually from
Monsters, Inc., and Monsters, Inc. is set
after Inside Out.
By this logic, Bing Bong must live on in one
war or another.
Gothel and The Evil Queen
There is a very popular Disney theory that
does a lot to prove that The Evil Queen from
Snow White and Gothel from Tangled are actually
the same person.
Right off the bat, the physical similarities
are uncanny!
If that doesn’t convince you, consider that
Mother Gothel has a dagger in a box, which
looks a lot like the dagger in the box that
the Evil Queen gives to the Huntsman in Snow
White.
Both women are completely obsessed with beauty
and staying young, too.
Disney doesn’t really do anything by accident
in their movies, so we think it’s very likely
that all these clues prove this theory!
Tarzan's Jane is descended from Princess Belle.
When you take a look at Belle from Beauty
and The Beast and Jane from Tarzan, you must
admit that they look strikingly similar, especially
with those matching yellow outfits.
It seems that the connection may not be without
reason.
In a scene in Tarzan, Terk is drumming on
a tea set.
The pot looks suspiciously like Mrs. Potts
from Beauty and the Beast, and one of the
teacups even appears to have a small chip,
sound familiar?
Some have speculated that could mean that
it was an heirloom passed down through the
family from Belle.
If this theory is true and we think about
the current adaptations of these stories,
that would mean that Emma Watson is playing
the great grandmother of Margot Robbie…talk
about good genetics!
So there’s our list of 10 Disney movie theories
that actually make a lot of sense.
How many of these ideas do you believe?
Have you heard of any other crazy Disney movie
theories?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more fun videos – like this one!